[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and watch this
video if you want to live I'm sorry that
was so bad anyway with terminated dark
fate right around the corner we've
slowly started getting new leaks about
the movie's plot and ending throughout
this video I'm gonna be breaking down
everything that you need to know about
the film's storyline and giving my
thoughts on it but those of you who
didn't leave after the terrible Arni
impression there will be heavy spoilers
here so if you don't want to know
anything about the movie then I highly
suggest that you turn off now without
the way I just want to give a huge thank
you for clicking this video now let's
get into my breakdown of terminator dark
fate ok so the original leak said that
John Connor was killed brutally by Col
at the t800 with a shotgun at a beach
bar in 1997 however the new leaks which
had been verified by several people on
reddit say that John Connor lives and
leads a new life without his mother he
observes the news but on the whole keeps
rather low-key now this makes a lot of
sense as by this point John's age will
probably make him far too old to be the
young up-and-coming leader of the
resistance
doomsday constantly being pushed back
has always been a big issue in the
series and I guess at this point he's
just too old for this ish anyway there's
not really a skiner anymore and instead
the software that causes the end of
humanity is known as Legion which is an
anti-terrorist program that becomes
self-aware with the memory of Skynet
Genesis did this too and honestly I have
no idea why they've changed this up
again as Scylla is such a cool name and
there's no real reason to change it as
literally no one knows about the rise of
the robots other than a select few
Judgment Day happens in 2020 and we
learn that in the alternate 1997
timeline that saw John as the leader he
sent Carl play by aunts watching her
back to protect him and he's existed
there till now the whole timeline thing
is really weird and basically boils down
to that Judgment Day did happen the way
that the original film stated that it
did however John did send a terminator
back and changed the future
thus creating this new timeline that we
now follow Danny Ramos is the new leader
of the resist
since not her child as was with Sarah
Connor and graces from the Year 2045
which is probably a nod to Blade Runner
2045 which also starred Mackenzie Davis
the new leaks say that the movie is
pretty much a film driven by female
warriors which has always sort of been
the case with the franchise I've seen a
lot of the internet up in arms saying
that the movie is trying to be woke but
Terminator 3 had a female terminator and
Sarah Connor was always portrayed as a
strong female so yeah I don't really
agree with that too much anyway the film
centers around Reb 9 a new Terminator
travelling through time to stop Danny
Ramos Reb 9 consists of a traditional
solid endoskeleton that is surrounded by
skin however unlike the prior TX
terminate and that we saw in t3 rev 9
can separate into two create two fully
autonomous terminators that can operate
on their own the Terminator chases the
characters across North America but with
the help of Sarah Connor they're able to
survive Sarah knows where to find them
because Karl sends her information on
where terminators are and this leads her
to cross paths with the group Col joins
them in the movie and at the end Sarah
Connor removes Grace's Power Cell to
sacrifice herself in order to kill Reb 9
however at the last second Sarah gets
knocked away from grace and Karl uses it
along with himself to destroy the
machine the movie apparently ends with
Sarah and John reuniting and deciding
that together they will train Danny
Ramos to be the new leader of the
resistance artifacts left over from Rev
nines destruction go on to create Rev 1
and thus the terminators will once again
resurface in the future and that's all
the leaks we have so far on the film
honestly it sounds pretty basic to me
and with this being the big reboot of
the film that was going to save the
franchise I feel like it's quite lacking
now action movies are all about
execution and I'm sure on paper even
something like die hard sounds
absolutely terrible so who knows this
could be amazing the movie is tracking
to do quite mediocre though with the
opening predictions being 35 to 45
million dollars which yeah for a film of
this stature is pretty terrible
Terminator 2 is one of the biggest
movies of all time and to see a sequel
predicted for this I think it's really
bad
now it may do better if the movie is
good
but I think a huge problem with this
whole thing is purely franchise fatigue
we haven't had a great Terminator film
since 1991 and this constant rebooting
of the franchise just makes it seem
pointless getting invested if dark fate
fails then it will be the third
Terminator film that has tried a
kickstart a new trilogy and hasn't
worked Terminator Salvation try to start
a new trilogy Genesis try to start a new
trilogy and dark Fate is trying to start
a new trilogy so I think people are just
fed up basically if this fails we will
have a trilogy of failed trilogies and
it just seems like if they don't pull it
off with this that it's time to end the
franchise and that pains me to say
because I absolutely love the series I
guess we will see what happens but yeah
for now I'm very lukewarm to the movie
and not expecting it to do well now
James Cameron is known for having the
most expensive movies of all time that
well no way ever make their money back
but somehow he still manages to turn a
profit so who knows I guess time will
tell or they will just send it
Terminator back and kill a franchise
after t2 we're gonna see obviously
though I'd love to hear your thoughts on
these leaks and if you think the movie
will be good or meh
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and make sure you check out my breakdown
of the leak - Joker footage which will
be linked at the end I go over
everything you need to know about the
recently leaked scenes as well as what
happens in them so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more if
you want to come talk to me about movies
TV shows games and comic books then you
can follow me on twitter at definition
whitey it's the best way to get in touch
with me and is the perfect place to
suggest new videos and content so
hopefully i see over there after this
also just wanna let you know that we're
giving away a free copy of spider-man
far from home on blu-ray and all you
have to do to be in with a chance of
winning is to like this video make sure
that you subscribe to the channel and
leave your thoughts on the Terminator
dark fate leaks in the comment section
below
the winner will be chosen at random on
October the 15th and the blue arrow be
shipped out from there to ever get
surprised it's the best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is the
channel for people who were mad into
movies so if that's the kind of thing
you like hit subscribe thanks again for
taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
[Music]
[Music]